cuando tratamos de decidir entre una
reacción de sustitución y una de
eliminación es importante tomar en
cuenta la función del reactivo el
reactivo funciona como un núcleo filo o
funciona como una base bueno primero
veamos el núcleo filo y vamos a darle
importancia a las cargas por ejemplo
sabemos que el agua puede funcionar como
un núcleo filo así que tenemos una
región de alta densidad electrónica
alrededor del oxígeno y el oxígeno es
parcialmente negativo porque es más
electro negativo que el hidrógeno
entonces estos hidrógenos son
parcialmente positivos así que el agua
puede funcionar como un núcleo filo pero
es un núcleo filo débil porque no
tenemos una región de alta densidad
electrónica como la que tenemos en el
ión hidróxido miren el ión hidróxido es
un núcleo filo fuerte porque en lugar de
tener una carga parcial negativa tiene
una carga formal negativa en el oxígeno
y ahora veamos la polar y zabi lidad del
núcleo fi lo vamos a comparar el ión
hidróxido con el sulfuro de hidrógeno o
también llamado ácido sulfhídrico ya
vimos que el ión hidróxido es un núcleo
filo fuerte con su carga negativa en el
oxígeno pero el sulfuro de hidrógeno
también es un núcleo filo fuerte aún
cuando no tiene una carga negativa en el
azufre y eso es porque la polaridad está
relacionada con el tamaño del átomo es
decir con la distancia que hay entre los
electrones y el núcleo bueno pues el
azufre es un átomo más grande que el
oxígeno tenemos muchos electrones que se
encuentran muy lejos del núcleo así que
el núcleo no tiene mucha influencia
sobre ellos y es más fácil polarizar
esos electrones entonces es más fácil
que vamos a decir que estos electrones
funcionan como un núcleo filo para
acercarse a un electro filo esa es la
razón por la que el sulfuro de hidrógeno
es un núcleo filo fuerte
ya habíamos visto que el ión hidróxido
es un núcleo filo fuerte pero aquí los
electrones están más cerca del núcleo
así que el núcleo tiene una mayor
influencia sobre ellos así que no es tan
fácil de polarizar pero sigue siendo un
núcleo filo fuerte porque tiene una
carga formal negativa mientras que
cuando tenemos algo como el johnny duro
sabemos que el hidrógeno es el átomo más
pequeño así que estos dos electrones se
encuentran muy cerca del núcleo el
núcleo tiene una influencia muy grande
sobre ellos
entonces como esta nube electrónica se
encuentra muy cerca del núcleo no se
puede polarizar aún cuando tiene una
carga negativa así que el ión hidruro no
puede funcionar como un núcleo filo
porque no se puede polarizar cuando
tratamos de conocer la naturaleza del
reactivo existen cuatro categorías
diferentes en las que lo podemos
clasificar la primera categoría es en la
que el reactivo actúa solamente como
núcleo filo y no como una base
un ejemplo de eso es el año en cloruro
el año en cloruro puede funcionar como
un núcleo filo porque tiene una carga
formal negativa tenemos una región de
alta densidad electrónica pero no puede
actuar como una base porque miren el
ácido conjugado del año en cloruro es el
hc él solamente agregamos un h más al cl
- y obtenemos hcl y sabemos que el h cl
es un ácido fuerte pero también sabemos
que entre más fuerte sea el ácido más
débil es la base conjugado así que el
año en cloruro es una base muy débil por
eso solo funciona como núcleo filo y lo
mismo ocurre con el año en bromuro y el
yoduro y después también tenemos los
núcleos filos de azufre que son los que
acabamos de ver el sulfuro de hidrógeno
es un núcleo filo fuerte debido a la
polarizada del azufre pero también
funcionarán solamente como núcleo filos
y eso es porque los ácidos conjugados
son bastante ácidos así que
se aplica la misma razón que vimos aquí
la segunda categoría es cuando el
reactivo solo funciona como una base y
no como un núcleo filo y un ejemplo de
eso es el ión hidruro ya vimos porque el
johnny duro no funciona como un núcleo
filo pero ahora veamos por qué es una
base fuerte mire si pensamos en el ácido
conjugado del h - si solamente agregamos
unas yemas obtenemos h2 y sabemos que el
h2 es una molécula muy estable por lo
tanto es un ácido muy débil y entre más
débil sea el ácido más fuerte es la base
conjugado lo que convierte a la unión y
duro en una base muy fuerte y si lo
vemos en una reacción podemos obtener el
yoni duro de un reactivo como el hidruro
de sodio entonces el nh es nuestra
fuente otro ejemplo sería esta molécula
que se abrevia como de vn
bn solamente funciona como una base y no
como un núcleo filo y tal vez piensen
que un par de electrones libres en el
nitrógeno podrían funcionar como núcleo
filo pero eso no sucede cuando tenemos
este sistema de anillos unidos porque
como pueden ver son muy voluminosos y
eso impide que funcione como un núcleo
filo sin embargo si actúa como una base
pero veamos que nitrógeno es protón ado
será este nitrógeno con hibridación sp3
o este nitrógeno con hibridación sp2
bueno resulta que el nitrógeno protón
ado es el nitrógeno con hibridación sp2
pero veamos por qué voy a resaltar este
par de electrones de color rosa ese par
de electrones toma un protón y forma un
enlace entonces ese par de electrones se
transforma en este enlace
y ahora este nitrógeno tiene una carga
formal positiva entonces tenemos una
carga formal positiva
nitrógeno este es el ácido conjugado del
tvn y este ha sido con jugador es
estabilizado por resonancia miren
podemos empujar estos electrones hacia
acá y después empujar los electrones al
nitrógeno
resaltemos los electrones los pondré de
color rojo este par de electrones libres
se movió hacia acá para formar un doble
enlace y estos electrones de color azul
se fueron con el nitrógeno y aún tenemos
un enlace con el hidrógeno por lo que la
carga formal se mueve a este otro
nitrógeno entonces ahora es de nitrógeno
tiene una carga formal positiva así que
el ácido conjugado es estabilizado por
resonancia la carga positiva es es
localizada entre estos dos nitrógeno y
como el ácido conjugado es estabilizado
por resonancia no es muy ácido eso
significa que la base conjugada es
fuerte por eso esta es una base con
jugada fuerte aún cuando es una molécula
neutra
entonces la proto nación ocurre en el
nitrógeno con hibridación sp2 y no en el
de hibridación sp3 porque si tratamos de
protón ar el s&p 3
no podríamos deslocalizar la carga
positiva entre los 2 nitrógenos y bueno
existe una molécula parecida al de vn
que se abrevia como debe y que puede
actuar de la misma forma es decir que
solo funciona como una base en una
reacción nuestra tercera categoría es en
la que el reactivo es un núcleo filo
fuerte y también una base fuerte y un
buen ejemplo de eso es el ión hidróxido
ya dijimos porque el ión hidróxido es un
núcleo filo fuerte y por experiencia
sabemos que también es una base fuerte
porque el hidróxido de sodio se usa todo
el tiempo en química general pero si
reemplazamos el hidrógeno por un grupo
al kilo formamos unión al co óxido que
puede actuar de forma muy similar al ión
hidróxido así que los dos son ejemplos
de núcleo
fuertes y bases fuertes y finalmente la
cuarta categoría es un núcleo filo débil
base débil y sabemos que la molécula de
agua es un núcleo filo débil no tiene
una carga formal negativa en el oxígeno
pero también el agua es una base débil
entonces el ácido conjugado sería h3 o
más simplemente agregamos unas yemas al
h2o y obtenemos h3 o más y sabemos que
el johnny trono es bastante ácido por lo
tanto tiene una base con jugada débil y
si reemplazamos uno de los hidrógenos
por un grupo al kilo entonces formamos
un alcohol que también es un núcleo filo
débil y una base débil